>>> A NEW REPORT FROM "THE
WASHINGTONOST" REVEALS TRUMP
ALLIED ATTORNEYS LED, QUOTE, A
SECRETIVE MUISTATE EFFORT TO
ACCESS VOTING EQUIPMENT AFTER
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S 2020
ELECTION LOSS.
THE POST OBTAINED EMAILS AND
OTHER RECORDS SHOWING THOSE
LAWYERS DIRECTED A TEAM OF
COMPUTER EXPERTS TO COPY
SENSITIVE DATA FROM ELECTION
SYSTEMS IN GEORGIA.
>> THE POST ALSO REPORTS THAT
THOSE TRUMP ALLIES ASKED A
FORENSIC DATA FIRM TO ACCESS
COUNTY ELECTION SYSTEMS IN THREE
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
A LAWYER FOR PLAINTIFFS IN A
FEDERAL LAWSUIT OVER THE
SECURITY OF GEORGIA'S VOTING
SYSTEMS CALLS THE SCOPE OF THE
EFFORT, QUOTE, MIND BLOWING.
"WASHINGTON POST" INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER AARON C. DAVIS JOINS US
NOW.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON HERE.
THERE IS AN ALARMING IRONY HERE,
RIGHT, IN THAT AFTER MORE THAN A
YEAR OF ARGUING, ACCUSING OTHERS
OF SOMEHOW ATTACKING OR
ACCESSING VOTING DATA FROM THE
ITALIANS TO THE VENEZUELANS, YOU
HAVE EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP ALLIES
WERE DOING THIS, CAN YOU
DESCRIBE HOW THEY DID THIS, AND
HOW WIDELY?
>> WELL, THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME.
SOME SHOCKING THINGS HERE IN
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THE BIGGEST NEW THING WE DID
LEARN IS AS YOU SAID THAT ENTIRE
HARD DRIVES OF ELECTION SYSTEMS
SOFTWARE, ELECTION SYSTEMS USED
TO THIS DAY ACROSS THE STATE OF
GEORGIA, AND ALSO WERE COPIED
AND THEN SHARED AMONG A
CONSTELLATION OF TRUMP ALLIES.
AND WE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU LOOK
BACK AT THE EARLY DAYS AFTER THE
ELECTION, IT SEEMS SO FRENETIC,
ALMOST AS IF ANYBODY, YOU KNOW,
WORKING OR INTERESTED IN TRYING
TO SUPPORT TRUMP'S IDEAS WERE
JUST TAKING ON THEIR OWN
VOLITION TO DO SOMETHING.
THESE DOCUMENTS SHOW IT WAS IN
FACT ORGANIZED, THAT
ATTORNEYS -- IN ONE CASE AN
OUTSIDE COUNSEL FOR THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, ANOTHER CASE SYDNEY
POWELL, WERE DIRECTING THESE
COMPUTER FORENSIC EXPERTS TO GO
INTO STATES AND WLHENEVER THEY
HAD THE HELD OF A LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIAL TO GO IN THERE AND COPY
AS MUCH AS THEY COPOSSIBLY COUL.
>> SO, AARON, HOW DID THESE
OUTSIDE COMPUTER ZPERTS EVEN
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE ELECTION
MACHINE SERVERS?
>> WELL, IN THE CASE OF GEORGIA,
KIND OF THIS NEW ONE WE FOCUS ON
A LOT IN THE STORY, YOU KNOW, A
FORMER ELECTIONS OFFICIAL HAD
TOLD THE POST AND WE PREVIOUSLY
REPORTED THIS THAT SHE LET IN
SOME TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO TRY TO
PROVE IN FACT THIS ELECTION
HADN'T WORKED THE WAY IT WAS
SUPPOSED TO.
SHE DIDN'T BELIEVE BIDEN SHOULD
HAVE WON.
AND SO SHE ALLOWED IN, IT TURNS
OUT, A PERSON WHO WORKS IN THE
BAIL BONDSMAN BUSINESS, AND THEN
HE IN TURN CONTACTED HIS SOURCES
WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, AND
EMAILS SHOW THAT ULTIMATELY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS AND COUNTY
CLERK DOWN THERE WERE RECEIVING
INFORMATION FROM THIS COMPUTER
FORENSICS FIRM THAT WAS IN TOUCH
WITH A FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIAL WHO WAS ON TRUMP'S
SIDE, AND THEY ALL WORKED
TOGETHER TO GET THIS TEAM DOWN
THERE.
ON JANUARY 7th, PARDON ME, IT
WAS THE DAY AFTER JANUARY 6th
AS, YOU KNOW, AS D.C. WAS JUST
REELING FROM WHAT HAD JUST
HAPPENED HERE, THERE WAS A TEAM
OF COMPUTER EXPERTS DRIVING AND
FLYING TO COVEY COUNTY, GEORGIA,
TO OBTAIN ELECTIONS --
INFORMATION TO CONTINUE THIS
IDEA.
>> DO WE KNOW, IS THERE ANY
IMPLICATION OR EVIDENCE, THERE
WERE ATTEMPTS TO MANIPULATE THAT
DATA IN ANY WAY?
>> SO THAT IS A BIG QUESTION
HERE GOING FORWARD.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHILE YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND THAT BACK IN 2020
THERE WAS SO LITTLE TRUTH TO ALL
THE THINGS THAT THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THAT WERE BEING SAID, I
THINK NOW WE HAVE TO RAISE
THE -- OPEN OUR MINDS TO THE
QUESTION OF HOW VULNERABLE IS
THIS DATA GOING FORWARD?
DOMINION VOTING SYSTEMS, OTHER
OUTSIDE EXPERTS, SAY THERE ARE
ACCURACY TESTINGS BEFORE AN
ELECTION, YOU KNOW, AND
AFTERWARDS THAT CAN HELP VERIFY
THE OUTCOMES.
BUT THERE IS NOW A QUESTION OF
WHAT CAN BE DONE WITH THIS
ELECTION SOFTWARE, THE ENTIRE IN
SOME CASES THE ENTIRE HARD DRIVE
OF DOMINION VOTING SYSTEMS, WHAT
CAN BE DONE WITH THAT
POTENTIALLY TO SABOTAGE FUTURE
ELECTION EFFORTS AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'LL BE LOOKING AT.
>> RIGHT.
SINCE THERE IS NO CENTRALIZED
OVERSIGHT, IT DOES APPEAR TO BE
A STATE BY STATE BASIS WHICH IS
A BIT ALARMING.
ON THE ONE HAND, THAT DEFENDED
OUR ELECTION INTEGRITY BY SAYING
THIS WASN'T CENTRALIZED, BUT IF
YOU'RE HAVING THESE EXPERTS
BEING ABLE TO GO INTO VARIOUS
STATES AND ACCESS THIS DATA, IT
IS WORRISOME.
WHAT ARE THE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS
AND WHAT ARE -- HOW ARE THESE
STATES REACTING TO THIS?
>> WELL THERE IS ALREADY A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION IN
MICHIGAN AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THERE HAS SOUGHT AN
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL TO SEE IF
THERE WAS A CONSPIRACY ALONG
THESE LINES TO OBTAIN VOTER --
VOTING ELECTION SYSTEM
INFORMATION FROM BOTH MULTIPLE
COUNTIES.
YOU ALMOST WONDER IF THERE IS A
PARALLEL PROCESS THAT CAN NOW
PLAY OUT IN GEORGIA.
THE PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS TOLD US
THAT THEY WILL PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE FBI, AND TO
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATORS.
AND IN FACT THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
OPENED UP SOME OF IT AS WE
UNDERSTAND, TREATING IT ALMOST
AS IF IT IS STOLEN INFORMATION.
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW
CRIMINALLY IN GEORGIA IS A
QUESTION, THE CIVIL CASE IS
RAISING THESE QUESTIONS OF WHAT
SHOULD GEORGIA BE DOING HEADING
INTO NOVEMBER AND BEYOND TO
ENSURE THE ELECTION SYSTEMS ARE
SAFE.
>> AARON C. DAVIS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, VERY IMPORTANT REPORTING
HERE, WE'LL CONTINUE TO FOLLOW
THE STORY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> NOW RECORDS OBTAINED BY THE
NEWSPAPER SHOW ATTORNEY SIDNEY
POWELL SENT A FIRM TO MICHIGAN
TO COPY A RURAL COUNTY'S
ELECTION DATA.
SHE HELPED ARRANGE FOR THE FIRM
TO DO THE SAME IN THE DETROIT
AREA.
WE'RE JOINED NOW BY MICHIGAN
SECRETARY OF STATE JOCELYN
BENSON.
SECRETARY OF STATE BENSON, THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
AS "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REPORTED STATE AUTHORITIES NOW
ARE INVESTIGATING ALLEGED
IMPROPER EQUIPMENT BREACHES IN
YOUR STATE.
WHAT IS THE STATUS OF THAT
INVESTIGATION RIGHT NOW?
>> WELL, THERE HAS BEEN
CONNECTIONS MADE BETWEEN VARIOUS
ATTEMPTS TO BREACH OUR SECURITY
AND I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE ON
MY END IS THE STATE CHIEF
ELECTION OFFICER I CAN ASSURE
ANYONE ANY BREACH TABULATORS
THAT WERE IDENTIFIED WERE
DECOMMISSIONED PR ED PRIOR TO T
YEAR'S ELECTION.
SO THE FOCUS REALLY NOW IS
BUILDING CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE
ATEMTD BREACHES AND THE BREACHES
THEMSELVES TO SEEK
ACCOUNTABILITY AND JUSTICE
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE, THESE ATTEMPTS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE, NOT JUST IN
MICHIGAN, BUT ELSEWHERE UNTIL WE
SEQUENCES FOR THE PERPETRATORS.
>> YOU'RE SAYING YOU TOOK THE
MACHINES OUT OF ROTATION FOR THE
UPCOMING ELECTION.
WHY?
ARE YOU CONCERNED THEY WERE
TAMPERED WITH IN SUCH A WAY THAT
MIGHT HAVE AFFECT THIS UPCOMING
VOTE?
>> IT IS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE DECOMMISSIONED
THEM IMMEDIATELY.
AND SO THAT'S -- THAT'S REALLY
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THIS EFFORT
THAT THERE IS AN ATTEMPT TO
FURTHER AND GAIN ACCESS TO
VOTING MACHINES AND THE TA
TAXPAYERS BEAR THE COSTS OF
HAVING TO REPLACE THOSE MACHINES
WITH ONES WE CAN AFFIRM ARE
SECURE.
>> WHEN WERE YOU FIRST MADE
AWARE OF THE SCHEME?
>> SEVERAL MONTHS AGO, ACTUALLY
EARLIER THIS YEAR, AND BUT IT
HAS BEEN AN ONGOING EFFORT, EVEN
BACK IN 2020, WHEN THE EVOLVING
ISSUES OUT OF ANTRIM COUNTY MADE
IT CLEAR TO ACCESS THOSE
MATERIALS.
AND WHAT WE REALIZED THEN IN
2020 WAS THAT A LOT OF TIMES
BACK THEN, RURAL COUNTIES IN
MICHIGAN, FOLKS AREN'T SXEXPECTG
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO SHOW UP AND
DEMAND ACCESS TO VOTING MACHINES
OR PEOPLE POSING AS LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHICH IT WAS SOME OF
THE TIME.
SO WE IMMEDIATELY BACK THEN
BEGAN WORKING WITH CLERKS TO
EDUCATE THEM ON THE FACT THAT IT
IS ILLEGAL IN MICHIGAN TO TURN
OVER SECURE VOTING MATERIALS TO
UNAUTHORIZED PARTIES AND THAT
WORK HAS CONTINUED OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS.
BUT A LOT OF THE COORDINATION OF
THIS EFFORT AND THE FACT THAT
AFFECTED MANY COUNTIES IN
MICHIGAN CAME TO LIGHT EARLIER
THIS YEAR ONCE THE INVESTIGATION
STEPPED UP.
>> THE FIRST QUESTION THAT
POPPED INTO MY MIND AS I WAS
READING THIS STORY WAS COULD THE
COPIED DATA HAVE BEEN ALTERED IN
ANY WAY, THE TALLIES IN EFFECT,
AND IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THERE WAS AN ATTEMPT TO DO SO?
>> WE CERTAINLY THINK THAT THERE
ARE NEFARIOUS REASONS TO GET
THIS DATA, PRIMARILY TO SHOW
SOME SORT OF ATTEMPT TO SHOW
SOME SORT OF MALFEASANCE IN OUR
ELECTIONS WHICH SIMPLY DOESN'T
EXIST.
SO IN THAT REGARD, FIRST THE
ELECTION RESULTS THEMSELVES ARE
SECURE.
WE HAVE PAPER BALLOTS IN
MICHIGAN.
WE HAVE AUDITS AFTER THE FACT
THE ELECTION WAS CERTIFIED.
THAT IS PROTECTED AND DONE.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER THE EFFECT
WHEN TABULATORS ARE ACCESSED IS
MATERIALS ARE GAINED AND THEN
MISAPPROPRIATED OR USED TO
SOMEHOW FURTHER LIES AND
CONSPIRACIES AS OPPOSED TO BEING
EVIDENCE FOR ANYTHING.
>> WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO
REASSURE VOTER AS WE APPROACH
ANOTHER ELECTION CYCLE THAT
THEIR VOTES WILL BE COUNTED AND
LEGITIMATE AND THIS WILL BE A
SAFE AND SECURE ELECTION?
>> THREE THINGS.
FIRST, AGAIN, WE'RE ASSURING
EVERYONE THAT THE MACHINES IN
PLAY AT ELECTIONS ARE SECURE,
THEY HAVE BEEN SECURED AND WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL PROTOCOLS AND
SECURITY IN PLACE TO CONTINUE TO
BEGIN TO AFFIRM THAT.
WE HAVE AUDITS AND PAPER BALLOTS
IN MICHIGAN SO OUR PROTOCOLS ARE
SECURE, THE ELECTION WILL
CONTINUE, BUT SECONDLY WE'RE
SEEKING JUSTICE.
I TURNED THIS EVIDENCE OVER TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL, SHE IS NOW
CALLED FOR A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
TO ENSURE THERE IS JUSTICE
BECAUSE THESE ATTEMPTS WILL
CONTINUE.
EVEN IF BY OTHER -- UNTIL THERE
IS REAL CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE
INVOLVED AND THEN FINALLY
REPORTING THIS TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT SO WE CAN ENSURE IF
THIS SAY NATIONAL TREND, WE HAVE
NATIONAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME OF THE TACTICS
USED IN 2020 REPEATED OR
ATTEMPTED TO BE REPEATED IN
ELECTIONS TAKING PLACE NOW.
MICHIGAN SECRETARY OF STATE
JOCELYN BENSON, GOOD TO HAVE YOU
ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.